elle restera la première femme candidate
de la droite gouvernementale à une
élection présidentielle valérie pécresse
représentera les républicains lors du
scrutin présidentiel de 2022 une
responsabilité obtenu le samedi 4
décembre au congrès du parti en
récoltant 60% des bois devant eric
ciotti l'heure est maintenant à l'union
de la droite notre rassemblement je veux
l'étendre à toutes les figures et les
talents de la droite les talents du
centre mais aussi les talents d'ailleurs
à tous les républicains sincères qui se
reconnaîtront dans notre projet pour la
france en juin dernier valérie pécresse
est réélue présidente de la région ile
de france une victoire avec près de 60%
des suffrages au second tour des
élections régionales largement devant
l'union de la gauche à plus de 33 % lors
de l'installation du conseil régional
elle parlait déjà de sa vision de la
france j'appelle à une france nouvelle
irrigué par ces territoires oxygénée par
ces provinces une france vraiment
décentralisée libéré
une france où l'état assurerait
puissamment ses responsabilités
régaliennes car la sécurité pardon de le
dire cet or une tautologie c'est d'abord
l'état à 54 ans valérie pécresse et à la
tête de l'exécutif régional depuis 2015
suite à ces nouvelles fonctions elle
démissionne de son siège de député de la
2e circonscription des yvelines en 2016
un mandat exercé depuis 2002 durant le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy elle a
occupé plusieurs fonctions
gouvernementales
d'abord ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur en portant la réforme de
l'autonomie des universités puis
ministre du budget et porte-parole du
gouvernement
l'autonomie c'est plus de liberté pour
les universités de faire des innovations
pédagogiques
de nouer des partenariats y compris avec
les entreprises pour la réussite des
élèves mais c'est surtout une culture du
résultat et de la performance
sorti de l'école nationale de
l'administration elle entre au conseil
d'état avant de devenir conseillère de
jacques chirac à l'elysée avec un
parcours politique locale et nationale
elle veut devenir la première femme
présidente de la république
pour cela un énorme défi l'attend faire
la synthèse de l'électorat du centre
jusqu'à la droite conservatrice tout en
convaincant les abstentionnistes